speaking of communication did you see a
rival you know you are the billion and
was the person to ask nothing
so no no no so I was I was so asked then
question I said I got it I got it I got
to do it right I went in to saw a rival
and when twenty days ago and I was going
to tweet about it I was going to be
shows you want to be the first to hear
mic on me you want to be like the first
yeah I want a later better fascinating
film yeah if you haven't seen it it's an
alien's visit and they have several
spaceships that park basically in
different locations around the earth and
it's not obvious why they came or are
they hostile and of course one land
america and america we shoot and then
ask questions if you survived the bullet
so we're very suspicious of them and I
think the most suspicious countries are
the ones who we know they're the ones
who who we know other countries should
be suspicious of us if we showed up on
their doorstep I think I think it's a
little bit there's a mirror held up to
us and that regard but anyhow so the
military is out in full force wondering
do they have hostile intent or not and
and they send a a linguist and a
theoretical physicist to investigate
this new life-form and I don't I'm not
giving much away here to say that by the
way if you have theories on this thing
you can give away the whole movie a
feature of the film and the aliens the
aliens way of doing business is that
time is circular to the alien it's not
linear to us time is linear an event
happens before in another event you
don't go back to it you may keep moving
into the future we are forever prisoners
locked in the present transitioning
between our past and our future so in a
rival however the aliens there not only
is their times
circular but so is their means of
communication and their means of
expression so it's interesting to see
what we have to do to wrap ourselves
into circular thinking in order to even
have a conversation with them so and now
this is a kazar so it's an interesting
exploration it is yeah yeah it's it's is
there any is there actual science to it
though uh there's some time travel in it
only because if your time is circular
you come back to where you started and
they have to address this in some way
yeah so and I I think any sci-fi movie
that thing's hard about put any time in
it is good it's the science real it's
what I'm asking me like aliens real it's
nothing I know it's very childlike so
just to be clear when I tweeted about
films in the past uh I've been I think
I'm deeply misunderstood yeah when I
tweet I think people see me as some
buzzkill next to you you know she
shouldn't invite to movies people who
read the book first right just haven't
stayed the [ __ ] home okay because they
uh they're gonna complain no matter what
I mean how many movies are better than
the book hardly any so I don't need you
next to me telling me what was better
shining was better than the book a
couple you know and Gone with the Wind
arguably was a really good movie even
though the book itself was great the
couple of others like that like Rebecca
was an excellent film and a first-rate
book but those are exceptions as we know
Wizard of Oz probably became up better
than the book Godfather
um sure sure so so but that's we're
handpicking them from the thousands of
movies tens of thousands of movies that
are out there so so when I comment on a
film my goal whether or not I achieve
this my goal is to connect you a little
more deeply to the science that it got
right and to think about the science
that might have gotten wrong and and I'm
not nitpicking there are things that you
got to invent just to tell the story I
give it to you alright but if you invent
something to tell the story and you
could have gotten real science to tell a
better story I will be all up in your
case you should and I also think the
people like because we don't know
science right we don't know the science
behind it so people tend to just trust
whatever is in the movie as legit
science what I want to do is hold the
directors and producers accountable to
getting the science right if they can
before they take their leap of
storytelling right and I don't think I'm
asking very much if you if you watch the
period film from the 50s and someone
there was
car parked on the street from 1962 and
your car expert you'd have right to say
something you'd say something and people
will be proud of you for noticing it